the Joe Rogan experience oh so how'd you
get in trouble would you just so I did
that with who does so that guy jungkook
ur I was running for that 25th dude what
the New York Times did in him was dirty
that was Derek who I shouldn't say the
New York Times I just say that writer
whoever that writer was the whole but
there was the LA Times see it was a
unbelievably York Times Juan was the one
with a job for ten years Duke where he
was like of course you're not racist it
was as clear as day that he was joking
it's clear as day that he was being
sarcastic
and so talking to David [ __ ] Duke
yeah the Grand Wizard of the KKK and
he's like oh you're not racist of course
you're not racist and then they take
that and put it in quotes he said to
David Duke of course that's right so
that's that's like mr. Smith goes to
Washington she's dirty but I couldn't
believe that was the New York Times that
hurt that one hurt because I was like
like you think it's funny yes it's
horrible
you've got me got Kyle kolinsky oh right
Kyle
yeah yeah I saw you I saw your interview
with Kyle I love God I heard we were
talking yesterday his the [ __ ] you said
good things about you always I didn't
get that part
oh I quit after you told him he was your
favorite new show oh you're my number
two I'll take it I think he's the most
reasonable of all the political
commentators but you're a comedian we're
and a political commentator I think you
have a dual status special when you're
funnier than him for sure oh that's V
that's how I Kirby he texted me
yesterday New York City was 68 degrees
yes he was like what in the [ __ ] is
going on then he's like I feel bad
because I feel so happy
it's like seasonal depression you know
what it's sunny out in 68 degrees like
yeah everything's great
meanwhile the world's on fire yeah yeah
whatever
it's warm it is warm yeah no he's great
there's that's the beautiful thing about
having corrupt and dishonest media is
that it opens a door for honest media
like you and independent guys like
yourself like pac-man
kolinsky it's easy this point of view
it's easy to do
and and MSNBC or CNN or it really hurts
hearing the the freight from a guy
respect the New York Times is horrible
that's always been what I trusted do I
know it was it was tough I was tough
when I when I realized that the
mainstream news media is just a
mouthpiece for the establishment when it
really matters therefore every war
therefore every war their repeaters that
how do we get into Iraq they got jet
Judith Miller to uncritically put
whatever Dick Cheney told her on the
front page that's why they all day of
aluminum tubes front page of the New
York Times and then Dick Cheney so Dick
Cheney tells Judith Miller they they
have aluminum tubes she printed on the
front page of the New York Times
Dick Cheney then goes on Meet the Press
and said look even the New York Times is
reporting this that's how they do it and
then Judith Miller gets it she gets an
on-air job and Fox News after that you
got rewarded there's that and then
there's probably also access to
candidates access to top official access
journalists you know if you don't give
them what they want they don't give you
access and this is sort of the game that
they've always played right that's
exactly right fact that they have access
and they they I've I've experienced it
but what do you think why do you think
they want a smear Jenk I mean like
because they see him as an enemy of the
Democratic Party because he wants to get
money out of politics right so that's
his big thing he has Wolf Pack and his
whole thing is I don't take corporate
money and that justice Democrats they
don't take corporate so that's this
whole thing right is about getting money
out of politics and they want to keep
money in power because if you get money
out of politics their whole grift is
over
[Applause]